[Music]
james is with us james is in phoenix hi
james how are you
i'm better than i deserve dave how are
you just the same sir how can we help
awesome just had a question for you guys
i felt a little
double-minded in this financial journey
kind of like foot on the gas and then
feeling like not having enough family
time and so then
swinging to the other end of things and
yeah just really not wanting to
go for it in life um
some of these financial sacrifices at
the sacrifice of
family and you know that emotional
connection with family so just wondering
even just practical
tips on how you can make that happen you
know well here's the thing even like the
top guy
if you did the stuff if you did the
intense thing where you're sacrificing
your family for an extended period of
time you'd be sacrificing your family
when you do it for a short period of
time in a sprint called gazelle
intensity like a year or two years and
you're busting it for a short period of
time you're not sacrificing your family
you're sacrificing for your family
because your kids are gonna have a
completely different life because you
got up off the freaking couch and we're
watching netflix in the name of family
time and went and did something instead
so the gazelle intensity thing usually
doesn't last 18 to 24 months because
you're out of debt how much debt have
you got not counting your house
um we're almost out of debt we just have
a few grand of medical bills that are
somewhat pending um and then we build
the emergency fund so where is it that
you're why is it you're going to be
intense for so long then
um i guess i guess maybe not even the
baby steps but just uh
just the idea of building for the future
sometimes
is uh you know it's a
sacrifice
yes
let me let me quickly just want to make
sure i'm not i'm not sacrificing family
at the expense of just building a happy
future look how many hours would you be
working while you're doing this
to build the emergency fund no to do
what you're talking about where where
you're losing your family i'm confused
you're working a 40-hour week or what
yeah i think um i think my wife and i
were both quality time people so we feel
you know the stress if we hit like 50
hours a week we just are feeling it so
let me tell you this if you are with
your family and you owe a bunch of money
and you're not safe you will be in the
physical proximity of your family but
you will not be with them
and your kids will feel that tension
that frustration
and they will think it's their fault
the greatest gift you can give your kids
is to set them up on a safe foundation
and if you owe somebody money you're not
safe i i would set your life up where it
runs perfectly after baby step three on
40 or 50 hours a week yeah if you're
doing that you should be that's the way
we teach that's moving from intensity to
intentionality and you're going to be
just fine if you max out at 50 a week
that's fine no problem
nobody around here is telling you to
work 80 a week after you hit baby step
3.